[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes al programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
la llegada de las vacunas supuso una
esperanza contra el hobbit 19 y ahora su
distribución y aplicación son un desafío
en los países del mundo
si bien la vacunación avanza por fases
los más vulnerables están al final de
las listas de inoculación naciones
unidas reconoció el trabajo de 153
países que adoptaron estrategias para
inyectar las dosis en tres desplazados
migrantes y refugiados aunque sólo 20
comenzaron el proceso de vacunación
entre ellos ruanda jordania serbia y
nepal da en eeuu los trabajadores
migrantes del sur de florida esperan aún
una dosis la falta de documentos les
impide recibirla a pesar de que cumplen
con una labor esencial en el país
organizaciones de ayuda buscan la forma
para que sean incluidos en las listas de
espera
estos trabajadores agrícolas en eeuu no
son prioridad para la vacunación en
florida la temporada de cosecha los
llevará ahora a estados del norte del
país como georgia tennessee y nueva
jersey y preocupa que no hayan recibido
dosis de la inyección es por eso que
activistas piden agilizar los trámites y
flexibilizar los requisitos para los
inmigrantes que trabajan en el campo y
es que muchos de los que elaboran aquí
no tienen permisos de residencia
y ya sabes ellos necesitarían una
identificación que tampoco tienen
documentos para proporcionar a la prueba
de domicilio o una licencia de conducir
válida y entonces así hemos visto que se
ha convertido más en un problema de
inmigración que de salud pública grupos
de trabajadores critican que el
gobernador ron de santis no haya dado
prioridad a los trabajadores del campo
como sí lo hicieron otros estados al
considerar los esenciales y nosotros los
trabajadores del campo no contamos con
papeles de los requisitos que están
pidiendo entonces qué será de nosotros
la pandemia nos va a poder ordenar a
todos porque sin protección y si nos
protegen pues ya se sabe que nosotros
somos los trabajadores esenciales del
país que si nosotros que sería que sería
del país tan valioso ese es el dinero
del país y tan valiosa es nuestro
trabajo en florida hay unos 100.000
trabajadores agrícolas una buena parte
son inmigrantes sin documentos que temen
presentarse a recibir la vacuna y pueden
tener repercusiones legales
si no protegemos a los trabajadores
agrícolas no protegemos a las
comunidades en las que viven y realmente
estamos continuando con la propagación
del cobe 19 los trabajadores migrantes
insisten en su importancia para la
economía y piden que se les abran las
puertas para recibir las vacunas
una historia similar se presenta a
kilómetros de eeuu y es que a pesar de
que él iba no prometía incluir a los
refugiados en su campaña de vacunación
human righs watch denunció que menos del
3 por ciento han sido inmunizados lo que
preocupa es que el índice de muertes por
el virus entre refugiados es cuatro
veces más alto que la media nacional la
falta de dosis la desinformación y el
miedo a ser deportados son algunas de
las causas de los bajos índices de
inmunización
abandonados así calificó human right
watch la situación de los refugiados en
líbano que no han recibido una dosis de
la vacuna contra el cob y 19 los bajos
índices de inoculación responden a
varios factores algunos de los
refugiados desconocen la importancia de
la inyección y no creen que pueda
solucionar el problema aunque la vacuna
esté asegurada para nosotros no la
tomaré de todos modos no hay conciencia
sobre la vacuna sobre lo que se está
vacunando vinieron y dijeron dos
palabras pidiendo que lo conociéramos
una mascarilla pero la situación es
temeraria como puedes ver caminando por
aquí nadie lleva mascarilla ni toma
precauciones
mientras que otros consideran que al
permitir la vacuna podrían ser
expulsados al lugar del que huyeron
si es buena para nuestra salud no
tendremos miedo pero si nos perjudica a
nosotros ya nuestra salud no la queremos
y si es para devolvernos a siria no
queremos saber nada de ella
la historia para los refugiados en
líbano no les permite confiar en el
gobierno y temen por el contrario un
posible arresto o su deportación
anexas realmente no ha habido ninguna
medida de confianza por parte del
gobierno libanés para generar seguridad
en el proceso y en las vacunas y si la
campaña de vacunación va a tener éxito
es necesario que estas poblaciones
participen y para hacer esto debe
abordar sus quejas y temores muy
legítimos y aunque el país no cuenta con
una alta cantidad de vacunas
organizaciones como human right watch
piden priorizar la atención a
poblaciones vulnerables
human righs watch está muy preocupado
por el hecho de que los refugiados
sirios y palestinos como los
trabajadores migrantes se queden atrás
en el plan de vacunación que hasta ahora
ha sido lento opaco y carece de
transparencia y que también ha estado
plagado de acusaciones de injerencia
política
en la plataforma de registro del
gobierno revela que sólo el 2 86 por
ciento de los vacunados donde
extranjeros pesar que constituyen el 30
por ciento de la población
para asegurar una distribución
equitativa de la vacuna a pesar de los
desafíos que enfrenta cada país para el
suministro la organización mundial de la
salud puede garantizar el acceso a
grupos vulnerables como a personas en
extrema pobreza refugiados de bajos
ingresos y trabajadores migrantes en
especial a aquellos que viven en
condiciones que no les permiten y el
distanciamiento ni un saneamiento
adecuado para evitar el virus hasta que
inmigrantes de france24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes de f24 sigan con
más información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]